is in Decline I reject that utterly
what we've seen in recent months is this
conservative government delivering the
priorities of the British people and
bringing our Global influence to bear
and some of the world's biggest
challenges
nowhere is that clearer than Ukraine it
was a pleasure and privilege to welcome
my friend president zielinski back to
the UK last week
his attendance at the G7 Summit was a
historic moment
when Putin launched his War he gambled
that our resolve would falter
that he was wrong then and he is wrong
now
Russia's military is failing on the
battlefield
their economy is failing at home as we
tighten the Stranglehold of sanctions
and the image of the G7 leaders standing
shoulder to shoulder with president
zielinski and Hiroshima sent a powerful
message to the world we will stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes
of course we've seen a huge Collective
effort across our allies not least the
United States
but I'm incredibly proud of our role at
the Forefront of international support
for Ukraine the first country in the
world
to train Ukrainian troops first in
Europe to provide lethal weapons first
to commit tanks and just this month
first to provide long-range weapons
and we've now at the Forefront of a
coalition to train and equip the
Ukrainian Air Force we gave 2.3 billion
pounds of military aid last year second
only to the United States and will match
or exceed that this year
Putin should know that we are not going
anywhere
and we know that Ukraine will not only
win the war but can and will win a just
and Lasting peace
based on respect for international law
the principles of the UN Charter and
territorial integrity and sovereignty
and Mr Speaker we bring that same
resolve to the biggest challenge to the
long-term security and prosperity of our
age China
as the G7 showed the UK's response is
completely aligned with our allies we
are working with others to strengthen
our defense ties across the indo-pacific
diversify our supply chains in areas
like critical minerals and
semiconductors
and prevent China using economic
coercion to interfere with the
sovereignty of others
concrete actions not rhetoric
but our Economic Security is not just
about managing the risks of China Mr
Speaker we're taking advantage of our
post-brexit freedoms with a hugely
ambitious trade policy we've concluded
negotiations on the cptpp a trade deal
with the world's fastest growing region
we've signed critical mineral
Partnerships with Canada and Australia a
semiconductor partnership with Japan
The Windsor Frameworks occurs the free
flow of trade within our UK internal
market and on Friday we announced almost
18 billion pounds of new investment into
the UK from Japanese businesses
that's a huge vote of confidence in the
United Kingdom creating significant
numbers of good well-paid jobs and
helping grow the economy
I'm Mr Speaker we're acting globally to
tackle illegal migration it is the
British government who will determine
who comes to Britain we must stop the
boats and break the business model of
the criminal gangs to do that we're
deepening International cooperation to
tackle illegal migration through new
deals with Albania France and just at
last week's Council of Europe starting
with the EU border force 2. and at this
weekend Summit we've secured agreement
that we will increase G7 cooperation too
so Mr Speaker our foreign policy is
clearly delivering for the British
people by strengthening our
relationships with old friends and new
from the indo-pacific to Washington to
Europe we're delivering a diplomatic
dividend for the UK and that's not all
we've announced billions more for our
defense the largest contributor in
Europe to Nato we signed a historic
agreement to design and build the Orca
submarine giving the UK Australia and
the U.S interoperable submarine fleets
in the Atlantic and the Pacific we've
launched a new program to build the
fighter jets of the future with Italy
and Japan
announced that in 2025 the carrier
strike group will return to the
indo-pacific once more and in Sudan the
British military completed the largest
evacuation of any country
and if anyone thinks the UK is no longer
able to wield hard power in defense of
our values just ask the Ukrainian
soldiers driving British tanks or firing
our long-range missiles
all that Mr Speaker is how we will
prosper at home and defend our values
abroad that's how our foreign policy is
delivering for the British people and
that's why on the world stage Britain is
forging ahead confident proud and free
and I commend this statement to the
house
I call the leader of the opposition
thank you Mr Speaker and can I thank the
Prime Minister for advanced site of his
statement and can I join with him in his
comments in remembering the victims of
the Manchester Arena bombing and in
marking the awful murder of Lee Rigby
Mr Speaker the war in Ukraine is
entering a critical stage Freedom must
win out over tyranny and Putin's
aggression must fail
as the ukrainians continue to defend
themselves and prepare for an offensive
to push Putin's forces out it is crucial
they know the nations of the G7 continue
to support their fight without waiver
we will stand with them for as long as
it takes we will stand with them because
their decisive Victory is the route to a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace
therefore labor welcomes the strong show
of support for president zielinski
we welcome the decision by our partners
on F-16 fighter jets
we also welcome restrictions on exports
that Aid the Russian war machine
and we welcome the tightening of the
Vice on the mineral trade that is
funding Putin's aggression
I would urge the prime minister to
prescribe the Wagner group as terrorists
and to ensure Britain's sanctions are
not just in place but enforced no one
has been fined for breaching sanctions
since the War Began
Mr Speaker as I told president zielinski
when I met him in Kiev
whichever party is in power in the UK
there will be no let up in Britain
resolve we will continue to support
Ukraine's military and its people in
their Quest For Freedom for peace and
for justice and when their moment of
Victory comes we will be there to help
them rebuild from the rubble of War
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that when it comes to Ukraine it is
important that we continue to show that
we are united across this house
Mr Speaker I also welcome the commitment
to de-risk our economic relationship
with China
it is in our national interest to engage
they will be crucial Global Partners in
the effort to reach Net Zero and we have
a trading relationship worth a hundred
billion pounds
but that Pursuit should never come at
the cost of Economic Security
and we should never leave ourselves
vulnerable to economic coercion
we must be clear-eyed about the facts
China is increasingly aggressive in the
Pacific
they show disdain for democratic values
and human rights and they are seeking to
exploit economic Leverage
a decade of ignoring these facts and
Tory governments closing up to Beijing
have gifted the Chinese Communist Party
a stake in Britain's key infrastructure
we need to change tax and labor is
willing to work with the government on
this it is time for a full audit of UK
China relations and to work more
consistently with our allies to develop
a long-term plan for Western engagement
and a long-term plan for Economic
Security
because as this winter has shown us in
the modern world Economic Security is
National Security
as the world races to invest in new
technologies and to make their supply
chains more robust we must make sure
British businesses can take advantage
the Prime Minister has rightly pointed
out the importance of the semiconductor
industry
they are the brains of our electronic
devices indispensable components of
cutting-edge manufacturing
the US and the EU have big plans to grow
and nurture their sectors to remove any
vulnerabilities from their supply tones
now we've waited a long time for the UK
to present its strategy
it finally arrived last week
and an industry leader described it as
frankly flaccid
does that worry the Prime Minister as
much as it worries me
whilst others build resilience and seize
opportunities this government seems
content with managed Decline and this
isn't the only area where I fear we're
being left behind
the U.S and the EU the US and the EU use
the G7 to continue important talks that
would allow European companies to share
in billions of dollars of U.S tax
incentives for electric vehicles and
green technologies and vice versa
last week we saw warnings about the
future of the UK car industry
people who work in the sector are very
worried
they want leadership
so could the Prime Minister confirm his
government will secure the same or
better access for British manufacturers
and when can we expect to hear progress
on this
when the influence when the inflation
reduction Act was passed the
government's response wasn't to outline
what opportunities this offered to
Britain
it was to say it was dangerous and to
suggest that an active industrial
strategy is somehow not the British way
wake up it's not the 1980s anymore a
race is on we need to be in it and we
need to win our share of the jobs of the
future we can't afford to be stuck in
the changing rooms complaining about how
unfair life is
Mr Speaker as the war in Europe
continues to raise Hiroshima was a
fitting stage for the G7 Summit a city
which has seen unimaginable Horrors has
risen from its past
it can serve as an inspiration for those
in Ukraine who fight daily for their
freedom their future couldn't be bright
from Ukraine to China to climate change
today's challenges are big but if we
stay United with our allies and partners
if we work together they are not
insurmountable and if we're focused if
we have a plan the economic
opportunities of the future are bigger
still Britain must seize them with both
hands and our future could be bright too
Mr Speaker I Thank The Honorable
gentleman for his comments at the
beginning with regard to Ukraine just
with regard to the Wagner group we have
already sanctioned the Wagner group in
its entirety and we don't as a routine
matter comment on prescriptions as he
well knows with regard to sanctions uh
in April we announced new sanctions
targeting those who are aiding and
betting the evasion of sanctions or
Russian oligarchs and in the integrated
refresh we announced 50 million pounds
over the next few years for a new
economic deterrence initiative that will
work on sanctions enforcement and
compliance in cooperation with our
allies with regard to China he asked
about our approach in clarifying it to
China that was done he may have missed
it in the integrated review refresh it
was spelled out clearly and indeed
warmly welcomed by not just foreign
policy commentators in the UK but
internationally around the world and has
been mentioned to me specifically by
leaders and Statesmen from many
different countries and as a template
that they have followed in their own
National Security strategies
with regard to cooperation with our
allies again that is something that is
already happening and we are leading the
way Mr Speaker you may have missed that
the G7 communique launched a corporation
platform on economic coercion something
that we spoke about and our integrated
review refresh and now that has been
brought to fruition which will be a
cooperation not just of G7 allies but
will over time be broadened Beyond to
ensure that we are working together to
combat countries when they attempt to
coerce other countries economically
um with regard to his final comments on
the economy Mr Speaker in climate change
and he points out these various points
on climate change and the g7s record
what he failed to mention is out of all
the G7 countries the country which has
the best record on reducing climate
emissions is the United Kingdom Mr
Speaker
so it's very it's very welcome that
other countries are catching up with our
record on climate change Mr Speaker we
applaud them and it's something that we
have fought very hard for them to do so
it is now great that they are doing and
I you know I won't mention there's other
points just to say that we do have a
different point of view we do not
believe that the way to drive economic
success and prosperity is to subsidize
the most Mr Speaker that is not the
route that will lead to the best
outcomes and indeed that was something
that the G7 themselves acknowledged
again I would Point him to the language
in the communique that particularly
warned against subsidy races are
pointing out that they were a zero-sum
game Mr Speaker when they come at the
expense of others and actually we should
be working cooperatively as we are and
lastly for all his uh negative talk Mr
Speaker the proof is in the simple fact
on Friday we announced 18 billion pounds
of new investment into the UK economy
from a range of leading Japanese
business businesses they have enormous
faith and confidence in the United
Kingdom why doesn't he
[Applause]
[Music]
because I applaud the prime minister's
recognition that the Chinese Communist
party is the greatest threat we face
that we must de-risk in order to keep
our people safe
we will engage when in the global
interest but we cannot allow the Chinese
Communist party to cast a defense as
escalation so can I urge my rightnerable
friend to consider three tests when it
comes to de-risking the first is
transnational oppression we must be
strong at home if we wish to deter
abroad the second is techno
authoritarianism we must prevent
Reliance on CCP technology that is
stealing our data and will undermine us
and finally we must uphold the
International rules-based System because
they are trying to undermine and to
capture it finally can I also urge the
creation of an economic Ramstein on
Ukraine that mirrors that of the
military because we have failed to
suffocate the financial war machine that
is allowing Putin to continue with this
war and he can lead that with my
rightnerable friend the chancellor and
it would make a meaningful difference
and end this war sooner
but also her work on on these issues in
particular with regard to her latter
question uh we just at the G7 announced
more sanctions particularly targeting
the military-industrial complex of
Russia's war machine which I think will
go some way to addressing her concerns
and point but of course there's more to
do and we will look forward to engaging
whether on it with regard to China I
think you know her points are all very
well made I I look forward to discussing
with her how we can strengthen the new
anti-coercial platform that we've
established it's something that I know
she's talked about in the past and where
we working with other countries can make
an enormous difference to more
vulnerable Nations ability to stand up
to economic coercion whether it comes
from China or other hostile States SMP
leader Stephen Flynn thank you Mr
Speaker would of course begin by echoing
the sentiments of the Prime Minister and
the leader of the opposition in relation
to the Manchester bombing and of course
the appalling death of Leon base so many
years ago Mr Speaker these symbolic
importance of the G7 Summit taking place
in Hiroshima goes without question so
too does the importance of the presence
of president zielinski in Japan it goes
without saying that Ukraine's war and
their fight for democracy is our fight
too and all of us on these benches and
across this house are fully United in
our support for the president and indeed
to the people of Ukraine in order for
Ukraine to be successful however we need
to Unity amongst all of those Nations
who believe in peace in that regard can
I ask the Prime Minister whether he had
any conversations with those Nations who
still are at this moment in time
importing crude oil from Russia and
indeed whether he expressed any concern
about other nations who may well be
benefiting from products that have been
derivative from that crude oil itself
secondly Mr Speaker addition to China we
did of course hear strong words from the
G7 in relation to that situation however
I'm quite intrigued by the Instagram
intervention of the former prime
minister I would be grateful for the
current prime minister's view in respect
to whether that was helpful and whether
he agrees with her that China poses a
strategic threat to the UK and whether
he would Echo those sentiments and
finally Mr Speaker in terms of the
economy it would be remiss of me not to
reflect upon the fact that the UK has
the lowest growth in the entire G7 our
economy is still below pre-pandemic
levels in contrast the likes of the
United States has seen their economy
grow by around 5.3 in the inter v9 time
does the Prime Minister and did he take
any lessons from those allies in Japan
about how to secure proper economic
growth yeah
prime minister
well Mr Mr Speaker On China our approach
is laid out in detail in the integrated
review refresh I reiterated it yesterday
and I won't go over it again but China
as I said represents a systemic
challenge it's the greatest challenge we
face in fact I said it's an Epoch
defying challenge given its both ability
and intent to reshape the world order
and his behavior is increasingly
authoritarian at home and assertive
abroad which is why we should be robust
in defending and protecting ourselves
against that on sanctions we are working
in tandem with the European Union and
the US to intensify diplomatic
engagement with Third Country Partners
to highlight potential circumvention
risks on sanctions and will continue to
do so and more generally on the question
of peace and discussing with partner
countries it was excellent to have a
discussion on Ukraine and peace with
partner countries outside of the G7 I
think perhaps one of the most meaningful
sessions of the summit where countries
agree to the principles of a just and
Lasting peace being based on the UN
Charter and indeed on the principles of
territorial integrity and sovereignty
that is very welcome Mr Speaker because
whilst many people may have ideas for
what peace in Ukraine looks like a
ceasefire is not a just and durable
piece and we will keep ensuring that the
peace that Ukraine has is one that it
deserves and one that is truly just and
Lasting
very much Mr Speaker could I welcome the
statement the work of the prime minister
at the G7 we are rightly rekindling
those international statecraft skills as
we see in Ukraine going from end laws to
main battle tanks training on Salisbury
brain the storm shadows and of course
helping secure those f-16s and with
China a more robust language as we deal
with China's aggression but of course as
we rightly step forward this will place
an Ever greater burden on our Armed
Forces I think he knows where I'm going
with this could I ask him when we're
likely to see an increase in the defense
budget to 2.5 percent GDP p
long Champion for this and rightly so
which is why I was pleased as a
Chancellor to increase our defense
budget by 24 billion pounds uh the
largest thing sustained increase since
the end of the Cold War uh just recently
my mom will run the chancellor added an
additional 5 billion pounds of spending
over the next two years to both
strengthen our nuclear Enterprise and to
rebuild stockpiles which is something I
know he uh has been interested in the
past and we outlined an ambition to
increase defense spending to 2.5 percent
but we're on track to get to 2.25 in the
next couple of years at which point we
will take stock and see where we are
economically and fiscally but as I've
said the threats our country faces are
increasing and it's right that we invest
appropriately to protect ourselves David
Mr Speaker can I join the prime minister
in paying tribute to the victims of the
Manchester Arena bombing and the family
of fusley Rigby Mr Speaker I welcome the
Prime Minister update he's right to the
UK and our allies must be steadfast in
our support for the Ukraine
he's also right to announce new
sanctions on Friday to further restrict
Russian businesses from selling their
products into the UK
now we must take further action to
support Ukraine that includes
encouraging individuals in this country
who are directly invested in companies
still active in Russia to sell their
personal shares now
does the Prime Minister agree that these
people should end their investment so
they stop supporting the Russian economy
and thereby Putin's War efforts
Mr Speaker we were one of the first
countries to put in place an incredibly
comprehensive sanctions regimes against
Russia we have sanctioned at this point
over 1 500 people tens of billions of
dollars of assets and indeed because of
our actions something like 200 and over
200 billion dollars worth of Russian
State assets are currently now Frozen
all of that is contributing to a
significant squeezing of the Russian
economy as we are seeing and their
ability to replenish their War Machine
and we will keep looking for other
opportunities to tighten the vice as we
did this weekend
Julian Lewis thank you Mr Speaker
all original expectations
Ukraine succeeds in expelling Russia
from her territory
will the time then have come for us
seriously to consider admitting Ukraine
to Nato so that no future Psychopathic
Russian leader will ever be tempted to
invade her again
Mr Speaker as the NATO Secretary General
has already said Ukraine will become a
member of NATO uh the the most immediate
task that face us is as The Honorable
for my Royal friend knows to provide the
support Ukraine needs to be successful
on the battlefield but also to provide
the longer term security agreements and
Arrangements that Ukraine deserves to do
that in a way that is multilateral
that's something I discussed with
leaders across the G7 because in doing
so we will send a strong signal to
Russia that we are not going anywhere it
increased the long-term deterrent effect
but also strengthen the incentive for
them to withdraw their troops now and
not attempt to wait anybody out with
gems
because many people in Newport
West semiconductor
including 600 hard-working employees at
Newport wafer Fab but after three years
of waiting rather than coming to this
house the Prime Minister made the
announcement in Japan on Friday last
week avoiding parliamentary scrutiny yet
again yeah yeah that is unacceptable in
my view how can we expect effective r d
to be carried out within the
semiconductor industry as trumpeted by
the strategy without well-funded
domestic manufacturing capacity
Mr Speaker the only lady may have missed
the billion pounds of investment in the
UK semiconductor industry contained in
the strategy the fact that it was
welcomed by Leading companies from the
sector uh it is it has taken at the
right amount of time to get this
strategy together because it is the
right strategy for Britain Mr Speaker
every country has different strengths
every country plays different role in
the supply chain we are focused on what
we do best which is in compound
semiconductors which you will know well
from South Wales but also semiconductor
design and IP those are the strengths
that we're investing in which give us
leverage in a very large global supply
chain which is why it was warmly
welcomed and it's the right strategy to
strengthen our security if you thought
among the many other achievements okay
can I
prime minister for ensuring that
education did not drop off the global
agenda and that the communique
reaffirms the g7's commitment to Global
education this is an issue that we the
UK have led on for many years there are
over 200 million in the children in the
world right now who are in need of
urgent educational support it's been
made worse by conflict of my climate
change so could I urge my right on the
phone for him to continue to encourage
our friends particularly France and
Japan to contribute to education cannot
wait
Mr Speaker I thank my honorable friend
for all her work in in this area
previously uh and she will be as I am
proud that the foreign secretary
launched the women and girls strategy in
March and one of the particular things
in that was to continue putting women
and girls at the heart of everything to
do with particularly with regard to
education and UK Aid has supported 8
million girls to gain a decent education
all part of our pledge to enable all
girls to have access to 12 years of high
quality education it's something that we
will continue to Champion in all
International Forum
thank you for your county declare an
interest as chair of the international
parliamentary Network on the World Bank
and the IMF but can I also welcome the
commitment in paragraph 10 of the G7
communique to enhance development
Finance to tackle the imminent debt
crisis tackle climate change and
advanced progress towards the
sustainable development bills wouldn't
that be an awful lot easier if the UK
actually stepped up and met the African
development Banks calls the hybrid
Capital match Japan's commitment to
share 40 of the new special drawing
rights and use the three and a half
billion euros we get back from the
European Investment Bank to actually
help now build a bigger World Bank at a
stroke that would help restore the
Global Leadership in development that we
have so needlessly and dangerously
squandered
Mr Speaker Donald gentleman failed to
mention that we are currently the third
largest spender in the G7 on development
Aid as a percentage of GDP we're one of
the largest contributors to funds like
the global fund and indeed the
multilateral institutions that he named
so we have everything to be proud of
when it comes to reform as we discussed
at the G7 and I began that workers
Chancellor we are pushing for reform of
the multilateral development bank so
that we can stretch their balance sheet
we are also pioneering the work of using
climate resilient debt Clauses in our
bilateral lending that was a specific
ask from the development Finance
community that we are taking forward and
indeed the common framework for debt
relief which is something I know he will
be familiar with again as Chancellor I
put that common framework in place and
we're now working hard to deliver
benefits of that to countries and with
sdrs I think I when I announced it we
were the first country to announce we
would recycle our sdrs that's having an
enormous difference every country
contributes in different ways but we
should be very proud of our record so
brother James
congratulate my right honorable friend
for putting Ukraine at front and center
of this G7 Summit and can he make clear
that this is not just because we believe
it is morally right to support Ukraine
in her own self-defense but because the
successful outcome of the war in Ukraine
is absolutely intrinsically tied up with
our own strategic and national interests
in that of the whole Western World up in
which our own security and prosperity
depends
multiple friend put it very well and I
agree with every word he says and I will
go slightly further as well ultimately
what are we fighting for we're fighting
for the values that we believe in of
democracy freedom of the rule of law and
honorable friend the only thing I
disagree with him honestly said the
Western World and actually what has been
striking and welcome in this conflict
has been the support of countries like
Japan and and I paid an almost tribute
to prime minister kashida in Hiroshima
for that leadership because because they
have recognized rightly as of other
countries like Australia and other
allies that our security is indivisible
whether in the Pacific or the Euro
Atlantic the values that we all hold
dear are Universal and we should all
work together and fight hard to defend
them
partnership with Japan is very welcome
indeed but the Prime Minister mentioned
some domestic Investments to well right
honorable friends from the police the
moments ago that's one billion pounds I
understand is focused entirely on
Research is he similarly committed to
manufacturing for example at Newports or
is he happy to leave that to Taiwan
United States and of course to the
European Union
Mr Speaker what we are focused on is
growing our semiconductor industry and
making sure we are resilient against
future shots now there are lots of
different ways that we can do that
indeed we just signed a new
semiconductor dealers acknowledged with
Japan and we will continue to find
Opportunities to do that with others but
the idea that we could insult a global
manufacturing supply chain into the UK
is simply not right what we should do is
focus on our strengths and we will
support uh manufacturing where it makes
sense and in particular in compound
manufacturing the capital intensity is
far less than it is in more basic Fabs
and chips so we've got a strategy that
works for the UK strengths particularly
works for South Wales and I'm very
confident that it will be successful
redwoodly
the Prime Minister quite rightly
mentioned illegal migration to be good
to hear what the G7 is proposing to deal
with it particularly in terms of a
cooperation by our French allies but the
truth is that legal migration dwarfs
anything from illegal migration in the
20 years the last 20 years the
population of the UK has increased by 8
million of which seven million are from
my legal migrants so what is a Primacy
going to do to back up the home office
in making serious efforts to stop legal
migration which is changing the country
forever which is totally unsustainable
and which we have promised to deal with
again the game
prime minister well Mr Speaker I'd my
honorable friend could probably imagine
that wasn't a topic of conversation uh
around the table in Hiroshima but what I
can tell him is I am committed and the
government is committed to Bringing Down
the levels of legal migration uh with
regard to Illegal migration cooperation
with allies is something that is
yielding tangible benefits for the UK he
talked about France the new deal with
France strengthens physical uh
cooperation of French forces on the
ground it also strengthens cooperation
and intelligence sharing the Council of
Europe last week we just opened up
conversations to work more closely with
frontex the eu's Border agency and Italy
will make sure that illegal migration is
a specific topic mentioned and discussed
and worked on in next year's G Summit
under their presidency and I will
continue to raise it in all the
international fora where I am present
Barbara Keely thank you Mr Speaker the
Prime Minister mentioned president
zielinski attended the G7 Summit one
thing that I understand is to him is
that Ukrainian culture has an audience
across the world yet there are concerns
that musicians from the Ukrainian
Freedom Orchestra and the national
Symphony Orchestra of Ukraine will not
be able to tour to the UK later this
year because of the heavy financial and
administrative burden of obtaining UK
visas the Prime Minister will understand
that funding Visa fees and traveling to
obtain the Visas is so much more
difficult for musicians in water on
Ukraine last year the home office agreed
to waive Visa fees and expedite the Visa
process
to allow you for any musicians to
perform here does the Prime Minister
agree that Ukrainian musicians still
deserve this support and will he ask the
Home Secretary to ensure that we do
offer this support as we stand with
Ukraine
Minister well Mr Speaker with regard to
Ukrainian culture in particular it was a
great pleasure for us to host Eurovision
on Ukraine's behalf which is fantastic
success and warmly welcomed by the
Ukrainian government and president so
let's get I'm happy to look into the
matter that she raised but as she will
understand our overwhelming priority
right now is to support Ukraine to
ensure that their counter-offensive is
successful and that will occupy the bulk
of our attention
thank you Mr speaker clearly the move
towards onshoring or near Shoring key
strategic products is since we saw why
that's so necessarily on the pandemic
and with other issues around but there
does seem to be a tendency to turn a
natural logical strategic need for near
Shoring key products into protection as
them across the developed world
what discussions took place about that
issue at the G7 and what can my right
honorable friend do to make sure we do
not revert to a protectionist world and
abandon the benefits of free trade yeah
my writable friend makes an excellent
point and he can rest assured that I
raised exactly that point with my
colleagues in Hiroshima he will be
pleased as I was that there is language
in the G7 communique which commits all
G7 countries not to act at each other's
expense and not to do so in a way that
is zero-sum competition but he's
absolutely right to identify the risk
other countries acknowledge it which is
why the G7 communique is strong on this
point and going forward you will see
much greater cooperation between allies
so that we don't engage in protectionism
uh which is not something that will
drive prosperity and growth in any of
our countries
can I welcome what the Prime Minister
said about China it particularly his
intention to diversify our supply chains
in areas like critical minerals
but the Prime Minister knows China
probably mines around 70 percent of all
rare earth minerals and produces around
90 percent of all processed Global
rareth minerals so what investments is
he planning to support in order to
ensure there is capacity anywhere in the
world to stop companies in the UK and
elsewhere being required to buy from
China you're here prime minister well Mr
Speaker no first of all we are
strengthening investment here at home
and increasingly playing our part in the
critical mineral cycling chain with
particularly with regard to recycling
which is the key part of how we can
ensure long-term sustainability and it's
an area where there's enormous growth
opportunity in the UK and we are
investing directly in that as you'll
know we've just signed critical minerals
agreements with Japan and Australia with
more to come as I continue conversations
with other leaders but in particular our
new economic coercion unit that is being
established will work to ensure that
China is not able to exert undue
influence on those countries which do
possess critical minerals to ensure that
they can trade those minerals freely and
fairly
Greg Clarke thank you very much indeed
Mr Speaker I should declare that I have
the honor to be the uh prime minister's
trade Envoy to Japan uh next week marks
the 30th anniversary of the opening by
the then Prince Charles of Toyota's
manufacturing plant uh in Derbyshire
it's been a tremendous asset for both of
our countries
does the Prime Minister agree that in a
turbulent World in which as my
radnorable friend says protectionism is
on the rise our two countries Japan and
the UK are more like-minded than ever
even more than at that time so will he
commit to work very closely with Japan
to manufacture the next generation of
cars as well as new technologies from
offshore wind to satellites and AI
prime minister well I can I congratulate
my honorable friend on his appointment I
know he'll do a superb job and I agree
with him and as the recent Hiroshima
records say I think the relationship
between the UK and Japan is the
strongest that it has ever been across
all areas whether it's scientific
collaboration trade and economic growth
or indeed security the partnership is
strong in the recent Accords that we
assigned will take it to an even greater
level of depth and cooperation on the
particular issue of auto manufacturing I
was pleased to meet the president of
Nissan while I was in Tokyo who had also
recently met with a Chancellor and as
you can see from the announcements there
is confidence in the UK economy and will
continue to work very closely with
Japanese automakers to ensure investment
in the UK and that we can make the next
generation of electric vehicles here
thank you very much Mr Speaker the Prime
Minister did finally mention climate
change in his response to the leader of
the opposition but in fact this G7
Summit was a disaster for the climate
flying in the face of expert warnings
that if we're serious about staying
below 1.5 degrees there can be no new
exploration of oil and gas and whilst
the communique did acknowledge the new
fund for loss and damage it failed to
deliver any new funding into it now
Oxfam has estimated that the G7 owes the
global South a staggering 8.7 trillion
dollars for the harm already caused by
their excessive carbon emissions so will
the Prime Minister now lead the way on
that Fund in particular and commit to
new and additional funding specifically
for loss and damage in advance of the
cop 28 Summit okay well Mr Speaker The
Honorable lady obviously missed the fact
that this was the first time there was a
G7 commitment to build stop building new
coal plants it was the first time there
was a G7 Collective renewable energy
Target and it confirmed that the
developed countries would meet their
commitment to provide a hundred billion
dollars in climate Finance and then
something that has been warmly welcomed
but again I would Point her back to what
I said to lead a real position she
failed to point out that of all the G7
countries we have the best record on
reducing climate emissions
as the Prime Minister knows it is
Putin's wish
and Ukraine's fear
that the conflict goes long and battle
fatigue will set in now my right
honorable friend has been very clear as
has the leader of the opposition that we
will give that long-term support but
what was his assessment of his
colleagues whom he met at the G7 and
particularly countries like India which
haven't always shown full commitment to
the struggle currently in Ukraine yeah
yeah I know as I pointed out earlier the
session with partner countries that have
been invited including India Brazil
Australia and others was very good in
confirming support for a just and
durable peace in Ukraine uh with regard
to his first point he makes an excellent
he makes an excellent observation and
that's why we have been working hard
with other countries to put in place
bilateral and multilateral long-term
security Arrangements is something that
I've long discussed with president
zielinski and have spoken to other
leaders about because my belief is that
if we can put some kind of long-term
multilateral security engagement in
place as soon as possible it will show
to President Putin that we are not going
away and that there is no point in
trying to wait us out because Ukraine
will get long-term support to defend
itself not just last year and this year
and next year but for years to come that
is an important thing for us to do and
he can rest assured that I will continue
having those conversations and pushing
that point with our allies all the way
in the run-up to Vilnius Summit student
Kenneth thank you Mr Speaker the
government's number one priority should
be to strengthen the resilience of our
economy so that we can stand more firmly
on our own two feet in this dangerous
and turbulent world it was disappointing
therefore that in his statement he
failed to make any reference to the
central role that steel plays a key
industry that builds our economic and
National Security and resilience so with
the with China and the US and the EU
government investing hundreds of
billions of pounds in their steel
industry can he set out what steps his
government is taking to ensure that we
build this vital building block of our
manufacturing base
Mr Speaker the government is committed
to supporting the UK steel industry he
who knows full well that I can't comment
on discussions that are happening of a
commercially sensitive data with
particular companies but he will know
our track record and higher's Chancellor
during the pandemic provided financial
support to a steel company in South
Wales because I believed it was the
right thing to do so if he needs any
evidence of our commitment to steel
industry particularly in Wales he
doesn't need to look too far
Richard Drex
a friend for his stance on Ukraine and
for successful G7
he rightly mentioned this afternoon the
problem of mass immigration particularly
illegal immigration without doubt one of
the aggravating factors is the eu's open
border policy was there any discussion
to re-look at that
prime minister I I said that no
discussion as you might expect at the G7
but illegal migration was discussed at
the Council of Europe uh last week when
I was there and as he can see we started
conversations with the EU about closer
cooperation with the eu's Border agency
frontex so we can work together to work
Upstream share intelligence and make
sure that we break the cycle of the
criminal gangs and he can expect further
conversations and cooperation in that
vein because ultimately this is a shared
challenge illegal migration was up 50 to
60 percent in the European continent
last year so we're not alone in facing
this Challenge and we will work with
others to contract constructively solve
it
Deputy speaker the Wagner group have
already admitted to murdering 40
children and hundreds of adults
Sheltering in a basement in back moot
mere sanctions are not a strong enough
message what does they have to do before
the Prime Minister will take action to
prescribe this terrorist organization
prime minister well Madam Deputy speaker
what we are also doing is making sure
that those that commit war crimes in
Ukraine will be held accountable and
will be brought to Justice uh which is
why we took a leading role in supporting
evidence Gathering providing for
financial and Technical legal support
recently over a million pounds to these
efforts and very much welcomed the
recent announcement of the ICC to bring
to Justice the war crimes that have been
committed particularly against children
and will continue to play a leading part
in the coalition to ensure that those
who do commit these crimes are brought
to Justice James Morris Deputy speaker
the global environment faces more
challenges than it has for many years
not not least existential threat to the
rules-based international order and also
threats to the essence of our Democratic
Values so would the Prime Minister agree
with me that actually the UK is uniquely
placed to build the networks and
relationships that are needed in order
to stop those threats from becoming a
reality
Minister my uh honorable friend is
absolutely right and we are uniquely
placed and I think the last few months
of our International engagement and
diplomacy has shown that we have strong
relationships not just in the United
States but across Europe and
increasingly in the indo-pacific as well
all those relationships are
strengthening our security both at home
and abroad and delivering real benefits
for the British people at Jeremy corbyn
thank you madam Deputy speaker the Prime
Minister mentioned the United Nations in
the context of his remarks about Ukraine
and he'll obviously be aware the United
Nations quite rightly condemned Russian
invasion of Ukraine could he make any
comment on the calls made by General
Secretary Gutierrez to attempt to
negotiate a ceasefire supported by
President ramaphosa and supported by the
pope and what comment would he make
about the statement made this morning by
President of Brazil he's right that a
ceasefire is not peace but any peace
process has to be started by a ceasefire
otherwise this war will go on and get
worse and worse
I could not agree with you I disagree
with the honorable gentleman more uh
Madam Deputy speaker a ceasefire is not
a just and Lasting peace for Ukraine
Russia is conducted an illegal and
unprovoked invasion of another country
it is committed heinous war crimes and
the right and only response to that is
for Russia to withdraw its forces from
Ukraine at and all plans of masquerading
as peace plans that are in fact attempts
just to freeze the conflict where it is
are absolutely wrong and they should be
called out for exactly
well congratulate my right on my friend
for the substantive and Central role he
played at the G7 Summits and the
important progress made in advancing the
G7 agenda of growing importance to our
security and our economy what is his
assessment of how far India is now
moving to share this agenda not least in
its relations with Russia
thank you sir well Madam Deputy speaker
and so the session with partner
countries including India and others uh
was positive in its conversation on
Ukraine and also on the principles of
what a just just and Lasting piece would
look like and it should be one that is
based on the principles of the UN
Charter and the territorial Integrity
being respected of countries and indeed
their sovereignty those are principles
which we believe in those are principles
in which the United Nations was founded
on and those are the principles on which
peace in Ukraine should be brought about
preserve to take a stronger stance
against Russia's Invasion and partial
occupation of the Ukraine prime minister
well in the amount of Rapid speaker one
of the benefits of President valenski
attending the G7 Summit was the ability
for him to talk directly to these
leaders as he did so particularly in the
session but in other conversations it
was very powerful message that he could
deliver in person and I hope that
message will go around the world and
people saw the symbolism that it
represented and as we see over 140
countries have condemned Russia and the
United Nations they remain largely
isolated on the global stage and we
continue to bring others to the cause
at Richard Graves mad objective speaker
the UK's key role in G7 Tokyo decisions
highlights the fact that this government
is doing more on the world stage not
retreating from it especially in the
indo-pacific region and Southeast Asia
where I had the island service the prime
minister's trade Envoy in his talks with
President Jokowi of Indonesia the
largest member state in asean and of
course current asean chair does my right
on friend agree with me that in this
last year of President jokowi's term of
office this is a good time for both our
countries to scope out the will and
capacity for a wide-ranging bilateral
Free Trade Agreement
prime minister can I thank my honorable
friend for all the work he does to
promote our trade in the region and
strengthen our relationships with
countries like Indonesia I did discuss
his particular mythives in person with
President Jokowi and we had a good
conversation on how we can strengthen
our trading relationship not least
through the jetco which we already have
and looking forward to build on that in
the future Patrick Grady
if it's the prime minister's favorite
resolve that it should never again be
necessary to use nuclear weapons why is
he spending billions of pounds on your
Trident
Deputy is Speaker look of course on on
this issue uh we'll disagree with the uh
with the Scottish nationalist party
um but we do remain committed to the
nuclear non-proliferation of
proliferation treaty uh which we are
signatory along with 190 other countries
that that offers us the best tool
available uh to bring about eventual
Global disarmament but that will have to
be step by step it will have to be a
negotiated approach because we have to
recognize the escalating security
threats that we face and the role that
our nuclear deterror plays in keeping us
safe is that woman and I'm Deputy
speaker at Qualcomm graph court and
armor among the major semiconductor
manufacturers that welcomed the UK's
semiconductor strategy the prime
minister's right to focus on where we
are best and where we can play an
outsized role in this industry at its
heart however this is also about
lessening our dependence on Taiwan can
the Prime Minister assure me in the
house that lessening our semiconductor
dependence on Taiwan will not come with
greater risk of seeing a decrease in
relations between China and Taiwan
prime minister Madam Deputy can I thank
my honorable friend for his comments on
the semiconductor strategy of course
it's an area that he speaks with
authority on our long-standing policy on
Taiwan has not changed and we have a
clear interest in peace and stability in
the Taiwan Strait and will
um completely resist any unilateral
attempts to change the status quo and we
continue to have deep and growing ties
in a wide range of areas with the Taiwan
whether it's on economic trade cultural
or educational matters
country western thank you madam deputy
Deputy speaker the Prime Minister spent
time at the G7 dealing with reports that
his Home Secretary may have breached the
ministerial code
would the Prime Minister take the
opportunity to update the house as to
whether he has yet met with his
independent advisor whether there will
now be an investigation into whether the
ministerial code has been broken and to
confirm that if the Home Secretary has
breached the ministerial code she will
be sacked
uh well amount of difference I can't
confirm that was not a topic of
conversation uh at the G7 Summit but in
the interest of being of being uh of
being generous
um I I've always I've always been clear
that we're issues like this were raised
they should be dealt with properly and
they should be dealt with professionally
since I've returned from the G7 I have
been receiving information on the issues
raised I have met with both the
independent advisor and the Home
Secretary I've asked for further
information and I'll update the on the
appropriate course of action in due
course
very much welcome the 18 billion pounds
of new Japanese investment for the UK
and will my right formal friend confirm
that he will be working to ensure as
much of that investment comes to
businesses in Stoke-on-Trent and that we
can grow the number of well-skilled
well-paid jobs in so content
my honorable friend is fantastic
Champion for Stoke and his constituents
and the great news about this investment
Manor every speaker and it is coming in
a range of different Industries which
means all parts of the UK I'm confident
will benefit whether it's in auto
manufacturing or indeed clean energy all
the industries of the future like
Quantum and semiconductors there are
fantastic opportunities and ultimately
that's why our International diplomacy
is working it's delivering concrete
benefits and jobs for people here at
home
Jonathan Edwards
the sanctions strategy against Russia is
being undermined by so-called leakage to
other countries for instance Russian oil
exports to India have reportedly
increased substantially a point I
suspect president zielinski would have
made to Prime Minister Modi during their
discussions at the summit did the Prime
Minister make similar points during his
bilateral talks with Prime Minister Modi
as I said Madam Deputy speaker the G7
allies are working in tandem to identify
diplomatic engagement with Third Country
Partners to highlight potential a
sanctioned circumvention risks and we
also as that are investing 50 million
pounds in a new economic deterrence
initiative which will back up our own
sanctions implementation and enforcement
Henry Smith Madam speaker I commend my
rice more friendly prime minister for
leading discussions at the G7 in
Hiroshima on countering and guarding
against the National Security threats
that are coming from China in that vein
will he consider blocking companies like
bgi who are harvesting genomic data like
they have done in the United States and
they have done in terms of Academia in
Canada from activities in this country
prime minister well uh Madam speaker I
knew natural security and investment
Bill gives us the powers to block
hostile investment into sensitive
sectors he will know that we have used
the powers in that bill to block uh
Chinese investment in Newport wafer Fab
for example we obviously look at every
transaction on a case-by-case basis but
we now have one of the most robust
Frameworks anywhere in the world for
protecting our companies and our
intellectual property from foreign
interference and Theft
Richard Ford Adam Deputy speaker liberal
Democrats welcome those parts of the
prime minister's statement that relates
to Ukraine but I'd like to take that a
little bit further and ask him about
Russian misinformation
President Biden said of the supply of
F-16 fighter aircraft that he has
received assurances that the fighter
jets will not be used to quote go on and
move into Russia
president macron said something similar
in relation to the supply of French
weapons but misinformation abounds from
the Kremlin about NATO's intentions is
the prime minister prepared like the
presidents of the United States and
France to talk about how British
long-range missiles are limited to
Targets in Ukraine for the liberation of
Ukraine
the defense secretary has already made
clarifications around uh our use of
Storm Shadow but we should all remember
what Ukraine is engaged in is
self-defense and indeed NATO itself is a
self-defense Alliance uh Ukraine has
faced an illegal and unprovoked act of
aggression and Invasion From Russia and
we should be able to give them all means
necessary to defend themselves against
those attacks
can I very much thank the Prime Minister
for his statement on the support for
Ukraine on behalf of the United Kingdom
of Great Britain Northern Ireland and
the prime minister is very clearly shown
that his words become action and for
that we thank him very very much and I
think every one of us recognize a good
day there can I declare an interest as
chair of the freedom of religious belief
appg I welcome very much the progress
that has been reported by the Prime
Minister on an essential trade daily and
yet I'd also like to know if possible
from the Prime Minister has he had an
opportunity to raise the issue of
freedom of religious belief with his
counterparts in an essential component
of any trade deal that must be part of a
core value of Human Rights alongside
religious freedom thank you prime
minister well Madam speaker I know the
foreign secretary engages on this topic
regularly with all our allies where it
is relevant and we will continue to do
so because we will stand up for the
freedom of expression and religious
belief not just in this country but in
countries around the world
I thank the Prime Minister for his uh
statement
um we now come to the statement from the
Home Secretary but before I call
um the Home Secretary
um can I remind honorable members that
they should not refer to any specific
cases currently before the courts and
that they should exercise caution with
respect to any specific cases that might
subsequently come before the courts in
order not to Prejudice those proceedings
statement Home Secretary
thank you madam Deputy speaker
with permission I'd like to make a
statement about the government's
response to the final report of the
independent inquiry into child sexual
abuse
the inquiry lasted seven years and its
findings are harrowing
widespread child sexual abuse going back
decades and shameful institutional
failures in child protection
each case represents an intensely
personal story of pain and suffering
of a child enduring something that
nobody should
I'm so sorry that anyone has
the interests of victims and survivors
are at the heart of the inquiries report
and of the government's response
I want to thank the more than 6 000
victims and survivors who bravely came
forward to share their testimonies I was
humbled and moved when meeting with
several of them recently
today is about ensuring that their
voices are heard and reflected in our
work so that future Generations do not
suffer as they did
I promise that their courage will count
I also pay tribute to the chair of the
inquiry Professor Alexis J and her team
for their Fearless commitment in
uncovering horrendous societal
professional and institutional failures
and for years of meticulous and diligent
work
we must use this moment to bring this
crime further out of the Shadows provide
proper support to all victims and
survivors and deliver real and enduring
change
this government has repeatedly shown its
determination to stop the scourge of
child sexual abuse just last month the
Prime Minister and I announced new
measures to tackle the evil of grooming
gangs
but there is zero room for complacency
and the inquiry's final report confronts
us with a necessary moment for further
reflection
it is more than a collection of
recommendations
it is a call for fundamental change
cultural change societal change
professional and institutional change
Madame Deputy speaker I am pleased to
say that this government has risen to
the inquiries challenge
we are accepting the need to act on 19
out of the inquiry's 20 final
recommendations this includes driving
work across government to improve the
victim's experience of the Criminal
Justice System the criminal injuries
compensation scheme Workforce regulation
access to records consistent and
compatible data and Communications on
the scale and nature of child sexual
abuse
the government response does not
represent our final word on the
inquiries findings but rather the start
of a new chapter
we will continue to engage with victims
and survivors with child protection
organizations and with Professor Jay to
ensure they retain visibility into our
work and confidence in our delivery
the full government response will be
published online at gov dot UK the Welsh
government has also responded separately
on these matters during relating to
Wales alone
I want to now highlight our response to
some of the most consequential
recommendations Madam Deputy speaker
we need to stop perpetrators in their
tracks and better protect and support
the children they seek to Prey Upon
to do this we must address a systemic
under-reporting of child sexual abuse
as I announced in April the government
accepts the inquiry's recommendation to
introduce a new mandatory reporting Duty
across England and today I'm launching
the call for evidence which will inform
how this new Duty can be best designed
to prevent the continued abuse of
children and ensure they get help as
soon as possible
the inquiry recommended a redress scheme
for victims and survivors of historic
child sexual abuse which the government
also accepts
of course nobody can ever fully
compensate victims and survivors for the
abuse they suffered but what we can do
is properly acknowledge their suffering
deliver Justice and an appropriate form
of redress
this is a landmark commitment
it will be complex and it will be
challenging
but it really matters
as the inquiry recommends we will
carefully consult victims and survivors
we will draw on lessons from other
jurisdictions and we will make sure that
we honor the inquiries Legacy as we
Design This scheme
now we accept there is more we can do to
ensure those who have suffered get
access to the provision they need to
help them recover and rebuild their
lives
we have already introduced the victims
and prisoners bill which will ensure the
criminal justice system delivers on
victims entitlements
it will also introduce a new statutory
Duty on local Partners to work together
when commissioning support services for
victims of sexual violence
but there but where we need to go
further we will
we will elicit views on the future of
therapeutic support including systemic
changes to provision through the
extensive consultation we are
undertaking on redress
it is right that we consider these
things together so that we can better
deliver the support needed by child and
adult victims and supporters as
survivors of abuse
the inquiry rightly demands proper
leadership and governance of child
protection since the inquiry's
recommendation for a new child
protection authority the department for
education's implementation strategy
stable home built on love has set out
major reform to Children's social care
although taking a different form we are
confident that these reforms will
fulfill the proposed functions of such a
Child Protection Agency and ensure a
coherent response across all parts of
the system to child sexual abuse
the government will however closely
monitor the delivery of our commitments
through our newly established Child
Protection ministerial group inviting
scrutiny from victims survivors and
other partners
we will keep this house and the other
place regularly updated on our progress
the inquiry makes two recommendations
relating to the horrifying and growing
threat of online child sexual abuse
the government's Online safety bill will
be a truly world-leading law that will
make the UK the safest place to be
online
strongest measures in the bill are
reserved for child sexual abuse leaving
companies in no doubt about their duties
to remove and report child sexual abuse
material found on their platforms and
use Technologies like age verification
child sexual abuse is a global crime
which is why we continue to lead work
with International Partners to bring
pressure to bear on the big tech
companies who must face up to their
moral duty to protect children
Madam Deputy speaker there is no greater
evil than hurting a child
this Landmark inquiry found that for far
too long stopping child sexual abuse was
seen as no one's responsibility
we must ensure that child abuse is
brought out of the Shadows we must make
it everyone's responsibility
and we must give those who have suffered
the confidence that their voices will be
heard their needs will be met and that
they will be protected
we owe a great debt of gratitude to the
victims and survivors who came forward
to their families and to their
campaigners
today is their moment and it must be a
watershed moment
I commend this statement to the house
Shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper
thank you madam Deputy speaker can I
thank the Home Secretary for advanced
site of her statement and join her in
paying tribute to the victims and
survivors of this hideous crime many of
those victims and survivors have been
crucial to establishing the inquiry in
the first place and also have been
involved working hard to make sure that
voices are heard and their strength
should be recognized their calls to
action must be heeded
there is no more hideous crime than
child sexual exploitation and abuse a
crime that preys on vulnerability and
leaves scars that I've felt for the rest
of a young person's life
and the independent inquiry set up by
the Home secretary's predecessor the
right honorable member for maidenhead
identified failings across a wide range
of institutional settings and including
local councils the Anglican and Catholic
churches organized groups and networks
and in each area action is needed to
make sure that that abuse is tackled
wherever it is found
can I welcome the government's
acceptance that there needs to be a
redress screen for victims and survivors
of horrific historic abuse
and can I ask her the timetable and what
the next steps will be on this as that
trauma can last a lifetime and is truly
devastating for those who experience it
but can I also say to the Home Secretary
the rest of the statement is inadequate
as a government response to such a
serious and weighty Report
I'm glad she's accepted the need to act
on 19 out of 20 recommendations that
it's not the same as accepting the
recommendations nor is it the same as
setting out what action she's actually
going to take for example the inquiry
said
that victims and survivors should
receive a guarantee of specialist
Therapeutics support all our statement
says is we will elicit views on the
future of therapeutic support where we
know that therapeutic support is
inadequate and we know that there are
lots of views already that was the whole
point of the inquiry to gather those
views and that evidence and on many of
the recommendations there is little
detail
and all she has done is simply point to
what the government is doing already I
really hope that there is more in the
full report that she refers to but there
is far too little to give any confidence
in the statement that she has set out
today
on mandatory reporting for child sexual
abuse labor called for this at near a
decade ago
the government finally agreed to do it
in April but all she's done today is
open a call for evidence well there have
already been lots of calls for evidence
in fact the inquiry gathered lots of
evidence and at best she could have
launched her own call for evidence some
time ago why isn't the mandatory
reporting in the victims bill that's our
opportunity to make progress rapidly and
it is far too weak in her response on
online sexual child sexual abuse
she's referred to the bill we know that
is long delayed and watered down but
this is not just about the legislation
it's also about the action that is taken
since then we've had an inspectorate
report on online abuse that would
describe the police response to online
child sexual abuse and exploitation as
too often leaving vulnerable Children at
Risk with examples of police taking up
to 18 months to make an arrest after
becoming aware children were at risk of
abuse there was nothing on that in her
statement what action is she going to
take on policing new evidence too from
the internet watch Foundation finding
that the number of web pages containing
category a material has more than
doubled since 2020 just in the last few
years alone and again the response is
Holy and adequate on charging we know
that the charge rates have got worse and
worse every year approximately 500 000
children will be sexually abused only
one in five of those are likely to
report their abuse
but only 11
of the cases that are reported result in
a charge down from over 30 percent in
2015. it has got so much worse over the
last few years that means the
overwhelming majority of child sexual
abusers are facing no consequences
criminals are getting away with these
terrible terrible crimes it's even got
worse than the last time we discussed
this topic in the house in October as
well and on child protection and the dis
the the barring service again we have
warned about gaps in the disclosure and
barring system again there are still
problems there and only last year we had
unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
being placed in hotels without properly
trained
DBS staff what has she done since then
even to reform Child Protection in her
own Department children and teenagers
have paid the price of the country's
failure to tackle child sexual abuse use
and exploitation
the rare home secretary's predecessor
did rightly set up this inquiry but
there is a responsibility on every
single one of us and in particular on
the Home Secretary and on the government
to make sure that there is actually
action that takes place this is about
the victims and survivors but it is also
about future generations of children
whose safety and lives will be at risk
if we do not see action
foreign
Deputy speaker I thank the Virgin lady
for her questions and her response and
the manner in which she's approached
this uh topic of the utmost seriousness
as I said in my statement the report
represents fundamental change to the way
in which we deal with child abuse and I
hope that the recommendations that we
are taking forward today demonstrate the
government's commitment to tackling this
evil she talks she asks about timetable
and Pace on the speed of the Rapport and
our response I hope that by normal lady
will appreciate that it is important
that we not only took the time to get
the report right or the independent
assessor Professor Jay but she will also
understand that is it vital that we
consider things thoroughly now so that
we make the most out of the
recommendations and we ensure that we
actually deliver the level of Reform
that will make a meaningful difference
on the ground to victims and survivors
and will make a difference in culture
and prevent this from happening again
this is reform on a level not seen
before it will Mark a step change in our
approach to child sexual abuse we need
to and we will get it right and if that
takes time that is time well spent I do
not want to give victims and survivors
the false impression that implementing
these big commitments will just happen
overnight but what I can promise them is
that we are today Heralds a new start it
it signifies a change in Direction and
it represents an acknowledgment of what
they've been through what they've
testified and the work of this inquiring
we are the government has accepted the
need to act on 19 out of the 20
recommendations we are accepting the
vast majority of these recommendations I
hope that reflects our genuine and real
commitment to get this right I've also
committed today to closely monitoring
police force data on child sexual abuse
both to ensure that the police are
appropriately prioritizing this terrible
crime but also to identify where they
need other partners like tech companies
to improve their own response let me be
clear we will do whatever it takes
whatever is necessary to protect
children from abuse no ifs and no buts
let me
issue a few thanks I want to put on
record my thanks to my honorable friend
the right honorable member for
maidenhead my predecessor for launching
this inquiry recognizing the problem and
starting this important work I want to
put on record my thanks to my right
number family member the Secretary of
State for Education the Lord Chancellor
and other cabinet secretaries who've
come together to support this government
response this will require a whole of
government response it will require a
multi-agency response if we are to
genuinely protect the interests of
children but above all
speaker I want to thank the victims and
their families for sharing their stories
for helping us to make this big step
forward I have had the honor of meeting
with members of the victims and
survivors consultative panel today I met
with professionals who are working on
the front line members of the police
force members and employees at the
center for expertise for child sexual
abuse hosted at bernardo's and funded by
the home office I visited the lighthouse
Center in Camden which provides real
therapeutic support to Children who've
encountered this kind of horrific abuse
and I've worked and met with the mpcc at
spcc I thank all of those professionals
on the front line This is a complex
issue
its in Norman tea cannot be
underestimated I'm enormously grateful
to the victims and survivors for their
courage this abuse should never have
happened but I hope that with these
changes we will make a difference and
prevent future abuse from taking place
we owe that to past victims and to their
families
Theresa May thank you imagine Deputy
speaker I'm grateful to my right
honorable friend for her statement today
when I launched the set up the panel
independent inquiry I said that people
would be shocked at the level of abuse
of children that had taken place in this
country and indeed the final report
showed an appalling and shocking level
of abuse not just historic but abuse
that carries on today
so the government's response is very
important those who wish to abuse
children will look for opportunities to
work with children in order to undertake
that abuse could my right honorable
friend please say a little more detail
about the government's response to the
number of recommendations in the report
on the disclosure and barring service
the use of barring of disclosure regime
for those working with children overseas
and the a barring of extending barring
of people from working with children who
are unsuitable to do so yeah Home
Secretary my right on my friend is
absolutely right to point out that uh we
need to enhance the rigor scrutiny and
standards within the workforce when it
comes to professionals who have direct
contact or responsibilities relating to
children and that's why the
recommendations uh several of the
recommendations relate to registration
of Care staff in residential care we
accept that recommendation the
registration of Staff in young offender
institutions and secure training act
centers we accept that and we are
exploring the proposals on how to
operate it we're looking at the
recommendations relating to The Bard
list of people who are unsuitable for
work and the recommendation relating to
the duties to inform the disclosure and
borrowing service about individuals who
may pose a risk we are accepting those
recommendations as well and we are
exploring the ways and the form in which
we can deliver those
Sarah champion
I have a long history with the extra
inquiry I was one of the MPS that first
lobbied the then Home Secretary and I'm
incredibly grateful to The Honorable
member for maidenhead for commissioning
this but that was seven years ago that's
seven years of victims and survivors
laying their stories out there telling
us that we already knew that this was an
epidemic and there are very practical
things the government could have been
doing in that time to prevent it so
standing here hearing the Home Secretary
saying she is accepting the need to act
isn't the same as acting she said
victims would have visibility in the
work that there will be consultation
that things would be monitored
where is the funding where is the actual
getting on with the recommendations and
what Home Secretary is the one that
you're not accepting you've not told us
that
well I've been fully transparent I've
come to the house today to set out our
response and we're also publishing our
detailed response to the inquiry which
sets out the detail that she's requested
but in terms of what this government has
done again I reject the accusation that
we are have not acted I I'm very proud
of the effort that this government has
taken so far to get to a point where we
are able to accept the vast majority of
these recommendations now the work
starts we need to ensure that we get
those recommendations right and we
deliver them in a meaningful way I'm not
apologizing for taking the time to to to
get that right that's why accepting a
redress scheme is a landmark commitment
that this government is making today
that will ensure that victims of this
heinous crime will secure some form of
redress we need to assess what form that
is not every victim or Survivor is the
same we need to ensure how that can be
assessed how it can be delivered to them
there are many many forms in which
redress can take we need to assess what
is appropriate for the victims listening
to survivors so that we can get that
scheme right I'm determined to do so
Deputy speaker I welcome the home
secretary's report it enixa's final
report they rightly said that the pace
of change of technology is of
significant uh concern and indeed since
that date I think some seven months ago
we've seen a seismic shift in AI
technology now ai will bring fantastic
benefits to society it already is but it
also brings threats and I know the Home
Secretary is fully aware of this and
that those threats are especially acute
I think for children such as the already
huge amounts of AI generated child
sexual abuse imagery that's being
generated and shared by pedophiles this
this report was commissioned as we've
heard by my right arm of a friend the
member for maidenhead some I think some
eight years ago and it's taken us that
long to reach this point of action so
can I ask my right normal friend in the
AI age where we can no longer wait uh
you know and take so much time to to act
yeah what processes has she put in place
to ensure that her department and laws
keep up with this pace of change in
technology
my right honorable friend is absolutely
right to raise the rapid pace of
development and Technology as a
challenge to Grapple with when it comes
to protecting Children online and I pay
tribute to his work uh when he was uh in
this place uh on uh protecting standing
up for child victims and taking a stance
against this heinous crime we are
obviously our Online safety Bill uh is
going making its way through Parliament
right now it is future proofed to allow
the regulator to keep Pace with
technology technological developments
but I am working from the home office
point of view with the National Crime
agency and also gchq to identify the new
challenges posed by AI there are
opportunities but there are real risks
posed by the proliferation of AI in this
field and we need to ensure that our law
enforcement agencies are equipped to
deal with it
and the Home Secretary has stated that
the inquiry rightly demands proper
leadership and governance of protection
of children an area that demands proper
leadership and protection is child
criminal exploitation a number of young
children who are criminally exploited
are sadly sexually as exploited as well
a situation where sadly we see a number
of girls by criminal gangs to be
multiply gang raped being artificial
performs sexual acts but these very same
girls when they report this to the
police are viewed as the gang members
they're not treated as victims does the
Home Secretary agree that for us to
treat this and treat those girls as
victims we need a proper statutory
definition of child criminal
exploitation
well child sexual exploitation is uh
abhorrent and this is part of our
response to stamping it out I would just
say that since the inquiry published its
final report we've published our victims
and prisoners bill now that places new
duties on local Commissioners to
commission services to sexual violence
including children according to need so
when that bill becomes an act there will
be new powers strengthened opportunities
to enable police and crime Commissioners
to respond to particular needs in their
areas such as the issue she raises
Alexander Stafford much indeed ma'am
speaker I thank the Home Secretary for
bringing this David to the house and
also for visiting rather ballet between
myself and victims of trial sex
exploitation only last month but as well
as helping survivors of child raping
their families like those who affected
and rather rather in brother Valley we
must work to ensure that those who
failed in their duties of care may no
among the whole political Authority does
she agree with the points I set out in
my recent ten minute rule that will
public offensive child sexual abuse bill
so that nobody who enabled or
facilitated or ignored child sexual
abuse should have any position of
authority
well I want to thank my honorable friend
for his very important campaigning on
this issue and his advocacy for victims
and I was I found it incredibly powerful
to visit him in his constituency and
meet
campaigners and and other victims and
survivors of child sexual abuse we are
introducing uh the duty to report that's
one of the key recommendations and it's
one of our key measures that we are
taking forward we want to get it right
we need to balance and ensure uh that
the roles and the responsibilities of
those in positions of authority whether
that's in local authorities whether it's
social workers whether it's teachers or
police officers are able to discharge
their duties and ensure that the right
balance is struck with protecting
children
Professor Jay makes clear that Duty a
duty can bring about a culture change
that's what I want to see
minera Wilson
Deputy speaker I joined the Home
Secretary and Shadow Home Secretary and
paying tribute to the brave victims
who've come forward as part of this
inquiry young people in care are some of
the most vulnerable members of our
society targeted by abusers because they
don't have the support networks that
other young people grow up with now
whilst thousands of foster carers
Children's Home staff and others do an
amazing job providing a stable loving
environment the report highlighted the
shocking abuse that many children in
local Authority care experience so will
the government be accepting the
inquiry's recommendation to amend the
children act 1989 so that the courts can
intervene when local councils aren't
exercising their parental
responsibilities properly
[Music]
okay
we do accept the the the amendment on
the children act to give parity of legal
protection to children in care I think
is the recommendation to which she's
referring and we accept in spirit the
need for parity of that legal protection
to children in care and we are exploring
ways in which we can best Empower our
children in care to challenge what is
going wrong in their care through the
independent review of children's social
care and National panel reviews but
importantly we have the National
safeguarding Review panel which takes
action and looks in depth into serious
incidents and that can discharge a lot
of the functions that have been called
for in this inquiry at Jackie Doyle
prize thank you madam Deputy speaker I
welcome much of what my right animal
friend has said here this afternoon but
she's quite right when she observes that
this is a question of cultural Behavior
and the truth is that state institutions
have failed these victims for decades
actually based on institutional bias
against their social background as much
as anything else and we know that
perpetrators are very clever at seeking
out their victims and seeking out those
who will be least believed and as she's
pointed out this really requires a whole
of government response to really
challenge the behavior of State
institutions to actually be more
Vigilant and take these things seriously
so could I ask just to pray a little bit
further how is she going to achieve
changing Behavior across the criminal
justice system it's only a matter of
weeks since she revealed the Casey
review which again showed some of these
behaviors and also in respect of the
lifetime therapeutic support for victims
it is now six years since the NHS
England committed to a lifetime care
pathway and yet local Commissioners are
still not commissioning those necessary
services so what will what could she say
this afternoon to make sure that the
government really do deliver on this and
it's just doesn't sit on the Shelf
I'm I'm very cognizant of that risk and
the one thing I want is I want to be
held to account for my words today and I
want another another update to this
house on progress on delivery of our
response uh uh in due course in terms of
how to bring about a culture change the
report is very clear I mean I believe
that mandatory reporting a duty a legal
obligation will direct and force
professionals Minds into a particular
way of thinking and that will be
accompanied by training it must be
accompanied by peer support but that is
how we will bring about a culture change
um so that we avoid and uh you know
eliminate this kind of
um uh turning a blind eye to apparent
problems which are of a heinous nature
in terms of support what the
government's done already I mean there
is there's been significant increases in
Government funding for victims of sexual
violence including child sexual abuse
the home office's support for victims
and survivors of childlike child sexual
abuse has been has got funding of over
4.5 million pounds and we've distributed
that to Charities who provide rightful
support the NHS long-term plan commits
an additional 2.3 billion pounds for the
expansion and transformation of mental
health services so that needs to now
ensure we need to ensure that gets down
to the the Grassroots level and reaches
the victims and and the survivors but
there is a lot of work that's already
gone on within government
five effort
speaker it's estimated that just one in
five of child victims report to the
police but in my experience in local
government
when we had
young people that were disclosing that
they were being abused
um was that they needed an independent
Advocate and an independent voice to go
to so that they would be listened to and
treated with sympathy and it's not
necessarily reporting to the police
that's required so what can the Home
Secretary say about what she's doing to
open up those Avenues so that people can
Report with confidence that they will be
listened to
well it's precisely the issue that he
raises and that's the reason why I'm a
passionate supporter of independent
sexual violence advisors is
also for idvis but they are also uh
relevant for children who are sexual
victims of sexual violence and we
already have a lot of uh We've increased
the number of isvers available to
victims of sexual violence including
children so that when someone makes a
complaint and they enter the criminal
justice system they will have an
independent professional who is on their
side to help them navigate a very
traumatic and daunting process who can
provide Clarity and can provide that
vital support that can make the
difference between a successful
prosecution and a an unsuccessful one
Laura Faris thank you madam Deputy
speaker I have previously declared an
interest because I was counseled to the
inquiry from 2016 to 17. given that the
inquiry looked at cases there were often
decades old there is a risk that we see
its conclusions as belonging to the Past
rather than the present but one of the
recommendations of the inquiry is
creating a protective environment for
children and although that will event
something different in some of the
contexts that we looked at we know now
from the children's commissioner that
one of the biggest drivers of child
sexual exploitation is the ubiquity of
violent online porn particularly when
the perpetrator is also a child
can I ask the Home Secretary therefore
what reassurances she can give that the
Online safety Bill really will protect
children from viewing this kind of
content and could I ask her rather more
boldly whether she would consider
working with her counterparts at dcms to
regulate the content of some of the big
porn providers like PornHub which we
know through a body of evidence hosts
and promotes child sexual exploitation
in some of its online content
well my honorable friend speaks with
expertise but she raises and she raises
a very important point with which I
agree the the ubiquity as she puts it of
uh online pornography and its
accessibility by children is a major
factor in uh the the incidence of
criminal behavior of this type the
Online safety bill will Mark a game
changer in the protection of Children
online and it will take us forward in
preventing children from accessing this
uh heinous material through the bill
companies will need to take a robust
approach to protect children from
illegal content and there will be an
entrepreneurial behavior on their
services and they'll also need to assess
whether their service is likely to be
accessed by children and if so deliver
safety measures for them those safety
measures will need to protect children
and they will have there will be
measures relating to age verification in
my mind that represents a robust step
change in how we protect Children online
Rich Jones thank you madam Deputy
speaker as co-chair for the all party
parliamentary group on safeguarding and
Faith communities can I thank the
minister for safeguarding for her letter
to our group written on the 12th of May
we appreciate that there are many
recommendations in the inquiry's final
report and that there needs to be
careful consideration of them but given
the years of historical abuse and the
years of inquiry can I urge the Home
Secretary to do all she can to ensure
these wrongs are righted and we see
action not more consultation for the
victims and survivors and as quickly as
possible
perfect
well I want to move as quickly as
possible as well and I want to get it
right for example the redress scheme
there are we have the starting point of
Professor Jay's recommendation and that
is a very helpful starting point we've
now accepted that recommendation there
are various models around the world of
how a redress scheme can operate
Australia Scotland more localized
examples we need to ensure that the
right criteria are established that the
process is robust and fair and that
ultimately the victims and survivors get
the redress the justice and the closure
that they see
inside
Bobby Moore thank you madam Deputy
speaker and I welcome today's statement
and can I put on record my thanks to all
of those who helped influence this
report particularly the victims of child
sexual exploitation as well as my right
honorable friend the member for
maidenhead for instigating this report
unfortunately child sexual exploitation
is something which haunts my community
in Keithley and I have held many around
table with victims and their families
who have had to go through the
incredibly traumatic experiences and I
thank my right honorable friend the
member for Whitton when she was Home
Secretary for coming up and listening to
some of those terrible stories and one
of the things that definitely came
across was this issue of trust lack of
trust and Trust um disappearing in the
very organizations that should be there
to protect the most vulnerable in
society whether that is the police our
local authorities or indeed the
Healthcare Systems
um and that was further illustrated by a
report by The Bradford safeguarding
partnership in live 2021 which only
looked at five children across the
Bradford District that has experienced
child sexual exploitation which is why I
want to see a full rotherham-style
inquiry into child sexual exploitation
across the Bradford District so we can
get to grips with some of the
complexities at a local level across the
Bradford District so will the Home
Secretary give a commitment to work with
all government departments on this issue
as it needs to be a whole government
approach not only with the department
for education but the department for
health and indeed the department for
leveling up communities and local
government because it is only when we're
all working with these departments and
at a local level with local authorities
and devolved mayoralties that we can get
to grips and Tackle this issue once and
for all
and I've pay tribute to all of his
campaigning on behalf of his
constituents on this very serious issue
the reports relating to Rochdale and
Telford and Rotherham are all very
powerful in their conclusions and they
speak to a very similar
situation to which he refers that you
know these professionals not taking
action that's what the mandatory Duty
seeks to address by placing a legal
obligation on professionals to identify
signs and indicators of child sexual
abuse providing them with the right
training so that they have the know-how
to deal with these very delicate but
devastating matters will be a game
changer professionals on the front line
will have at the Forefront of their
professional training what child sexual
abuse looks like how to identify it and
what action to take to stop it
uh Toby Perkins thank you very much
Madam Deputy speaker the recent
appalling court case into the murder of
Finley Bowden which led to the
conviction uh of murder uh of his uh by
his parents
um exposed very serious questions about
the social work practice at Derbyshire
social services and indeed uh the
actions taken by the court and for that
reason this recommendation of the
creation of a new child protection
authority was very much welcomed can the
Home Secretary tell us what specifically
the proposed functions of a child
protection agency that she now believes
will be better delivered by the
department for education's
implementation strategy are and why she
believes that approach is better than
the creation of the child protection
authority that was recommended in this
report
may I put on record my sympathies
uh to the family of uh right on The
Honorable friend The Honorable
gentleman's uh constituents
um when it comes to the child protection
authority we absolutely agree that we
need a sharper focus on improving
practice in child protection and
ensuring that we're all playing our part
to keep children safe and since their
inquiry reported the department for
education is in responding uh the to the
care of you has set out a bold vision
for reform of social care and child
protections stable homes built on love
and the government is confident that
those reforms will deliver the intention
behind the inquiry's recommendation for
a new child protection authority
Helen Hayes thank you madam Deputy
speaker can I put on record my tribute
to my constituents who gave evidence to
the inquiry
they relived their trauma so that
changes can be made in the future and
they are amongst the most courageous
people I know one of the recommendations
from mixer's final report is for the
introduction of arrangements for the
registration of Staff working in care
roles in children's homes including
secure children's homes this is an
obvious practical recommendation which
would make a material difference to the
safety of children living in local
Authority care
but it was originally recommended in
2018 and there was really no excuse for
the government not to act at that time
to implement it since that time children
have continued to suffer abuse and
neglect in children's homes including
those run by the Hesley group in
Doncaster and the calcott homes in
Oxfordshire can I ask the Home Secretary
why she waited five years to act and can
she update the house on the time scale
for implementing this very important
recommendation
yeah
well we accept uh the the the kind of
meaning and the significance of
recommendation seven to which she refers
registration of Staff working in care
roles in children's homes we are
exploring the proposals to introduce
professional registration of the
residential Child Care Workforce as part
of the stable homes built on love
strategy key and landmark reforms to our
care system but we recognize the
important contribution of the
residential Child Care Workforce in
caring for some of the most vulnerable
children in our society and the
importance of ensuring that they have
the skills required to safeguard support
and care for those children we're
backing them with investment and reform
I thank the Home Secretary for her
statement
uh point of order Crispin blunt when
we're talking about I'm Deputy speaker
um last Thursday there was a debate on
psilocybin access rights a technical and
detailed area policy changes to which
our hoped to transform the affected
effectiveness of current mental health
treatments
how can backbenchers
successfully use the procedures of this
house to enable debate
to hold the government to account for
proposed policy changes they will not
make if the responsible Minister will
not reply to the debates particularly
when the debates are led by colleagues
who have long made personal study of
that particular area of policy such as
the honorable member for Inver Clyde and
myself Madam Deputy speaker but notice
when they are then reinforced by the
harrowing personal experience of
honorable members of this house such as
the honorable lady for Warrington North
well I am uh I'm grateful to The
Honorable gentleman for giving me notice
of his point of order
um
I believe that the minute as the
minister is here I believe that he would
like to so I suggest that we ask the
minister to make a brief response
briefly and I regret that I wasn't uh in
Parliament at the time of the debate I
did give my honorable friend advance
notice of that I was at the defense
establishment important down at the time
as often happens another home office
Minister a very capable home office
Minister replied I have previously met
uh one to one with the member for
Warrington North to discuss this in
detail and reply to an adgerman debate
just a few weeks ago as I said at the
time I have subsequent to those two the
debate and the meeting asked the acmd to
accelerate their work on removing
barriers to research for all schedule
one drugs including psilocybin so I can
take this opportunity to assure my
normal friend that work I have asked for
it to be accelerated and the calls that
he and other members have made have been
heard
uh
further
um
I mean I
I just given quite a long response but
Brett's sale
um there was an inaccuracy in my right
or friend's response uh he well I
alerted him to the date of the second
debate on Silas Island Access rights on
the 18th of May he did tell me that he
had an engagement that day
um however it never occurred to me for a
moment that he would put that engagement
ahead of his duty replying to his house
and I suddenly got no communication at
all that he had made a decision not to
attend a parliament to reply to that
debate
it's not really my responsibility
to decide which ministers respond to
debates but I I I
do you think it is courteous that the
minister has come here today and has
given an explanation and I suggest if
the honorable gentleman isn't satisfied
with that response I'm sure he will
pursue it with the minister
um perhaps a meeting
um might be arranged but I don't really
want to prolong this too much further
because I think we're just in danger of
um going backwards and and forwards over
the same issue and The Honorable
gentleman is clearly
um not happy that the minister here
wasn't there for the debate but the
ministers explained his reasons The
Honorable gentleman may not be happy
with those reasons but there is not a
great deal I can do about that but I do
think that his point has been heard and
I suggest that
um I believe we have to move on to
another point of order our own Toms I'm
Deputy speaker thank you and earlier
this afternoon at home office questions
the immigration Minister who I have
notified of this point of order appeared
to suggest that it was somehow my
responsibility that there had been no
Asylum Seekers through the dispersal
scheme housed in Midlothian and
midlothians are very warm and welcoming
community and indeed we are looking
forward to welcoming anyone from
anywhere at any time now Madame Deputy
is because the reason for my point of
order is that despite the minister
suggesting that there had been no
attempts to have any Asylum Seekers
through the dispersal scheme house in
Midlothian I was notified on the 22nd of
February of the home office's intention
to house Asylum seekers in my Midlothian
constituency but then again on the 1st
of March the home office notified me
that they no longer intended to proceed
with that dispersal now perhaps Madame
Deputy is because maybe not for me to
say but if the home office were to
engage with local Authority is our local
councils or the Scottish government
these sort of issues could be dealt with
but I'd ask you for your advice as to
how I can best ensure that the record is
correct to ensure that there is no slur
in the Midlothian constituency as a any
way suggesting it's not welcoming of
anyone from any background coming to it
and how the record can be corrected to
reflect that
um well I Thank The Honorable gentleman
for that point of order
um he doesn't have to notify ministers
that he intends to raise a point of
order but I don't know whether he did at
all not okay well
um he has uh made his view very clear
about what the minister said
um I uh I know that there are honorable
members present um pps's who it feels to
me that they are going to report back
what he has said
um very quickly as I'm sure that the
whips will he's put his point of view on
the record and I'm sure that if any
necessary Corrections need to be made
the minister
um would do so or he may communicate
directly with the honorable gentleman
thank you thank you
[Applause]
Clark will now proceed to read the
orders of the day
non-domestic rating bill committee
now order
I'm gonna do
order
non-domestic rating bill
before we before I I call
um the uh mover of amendment four I just
want to remind the committee that while
I'm in the chair